A sci-fi legend is back in "Avatar:The Way of Water" — somehow!
Sohow does that work? Spoilers ahead!
"Avatar" fans will of course recall
that Sigourney Weaver's character in
the groundbreaking 2009 film, Dr. Grace
Augustine, died near the end of the movie
after being fatally wounded during an
escape. So when it was announced that
the "Aliens" star would be reuniting with
James Cameron and company for the sequel
shortly after the first film's release, it
obviously left fans scratching their heads.
"What's wrong with this picture?!"
Sequel "Avatar: The Way of Water" not
only revisits Jake Sully and Neytiri,
but also introduces us to their
Na'vi children including Lo'ak,
Neteyam and Tuk. Possibly more significant than
any of their biological offspring, however,
is their adopted Na'vi daughter
Kiri, played by Sigourney Weaver.
The biological daughter of Dr. Augustine, Kiri
is taken in by Sully and his family and comes
along with them as they must leave their forest
home and live amongst the Metkayina ocean clan.
Kiri is more than an excuse to bring Weaver back
into the franchise, however, as the character's
significance to "Way of Water" could very
well signify big things to come down the line.
Kiri is introduced early on in "Avatar:
The Way of Water" as Dr. Augustine's daughter
— although rather than being born human,
she is a full-on Na'vi from the start. As director
James Cameron explained to Entertainment Weekly,
This also plays into Kiri's character,
as she longs to connect with her deceased
mother while remaining self-conscious
about living up to her Na'vi family.
She has a special connection to the environment
around her, which takes on a new life when she
and Sully's family are forced out of their home
by a vengeful Colonel Quaritch and make base with
the Metkayina people. As Kiri explores the lush
oceans and comes face-to-face with the water's
colorful inhabitants, she also finds new ways to
connect and utilizes her abilities in unique ways.
She not only connects with the underwater Tree
of Souls and claims to hear the heartbeat of
the deity Eywa, but is also able to
communicate with the sea creatures,
which comes in handy during the film's climax.
Kiri's abilities make her stand out enough
from her motion-captured co-stars, but it is
her viewpoint on life that could spell a bigger
picture for the upcoming "Avatar" sequels. By the
end of "The Way of Water," we know that the war
between the Na'vi and humanity is far from over.
But just as Colonel Quaritch's son Spider, who
shares a close bond with Kiri, has love for both
the human and Na'vi world, Kiri's non-violent
ways and connection with the world around her
could turn the tide by showcasing a different
way around the seemingly never-ending conflict.
As the "Avatar" franchise is very much about
humanity's exploitation of natural resources,
Kiri could be the key to unlocking how to
better utilize those elements for good.
On top of that, we still don't know who Kiri's
father is, or even if she has one. We know she
has her limits, as is evident when she suffers a
seizure while trying to connect to the underwater
Tree of Souls, so learning more about her
origins might be able to help figure out why.
Kiri is one of the many mysteries in "The
Way of Water," but she's one that Sigourney
Weaver is prepared to explore. As she
says in a recent interview with D23,